foreign
[Applause]
out of your many years on Dancing With
the Stars um who were your most
memorable Partners who do you think not
to diss the others just who's somebody
that stood out my wife oh well
yeah my wife that's why you're still
married
[Applause]
one of the biggest Pleasures is the
dynamic personalities and people that
you go through this process with and and
it's I don't want to say a gauntlet but
it is something that really brings
people together uh and one of the
partners that I had a privilege to be a
pro partner with on Dancing With the
Stars Zendaya oh yeah yeah oh yeah I
forgot
and that she was young right she was 16
and she was just kind of trying to
transition out of the Disney yeah uh
star and yeah the rest is history that
and yeah that's great that's a crazy
career that one she's so talented so
talented so max does it ever bother you
that um Val won twice and you know you
[Laughter]
because he won twice my wife won twice
okay his wife won twice oh my gosh
my six-year-old was in my wife's belly I
guess when they weren't together so he
has a half a trophy I only have one in
17 Seasons but you know I gotta say that
my best partner was probably the show
itself oh you know 17 seasons of
incredible opportunities uh look at us
now yeah so we're grateful that's a
great answer yeah
this is why I love being
part of living with but also the coaches
it like kind of lets you kind of
reinvent yourself too in a way and
that's really cool how shows allow
people to really stretch their creative
muscles
well we kind of like take for granted
sometimes is the people that we gathered
in those shows are your core fans your
core audience it's the support system
that you have nowadays social media
craziness we can rely on people we've
never met I don't even know where they
live but I can always get this nice
message that makes me feel like you know
what I'm gonna go out I'm gonna do it
again no matter what the critics say
because there's people that really
that's why you're really here are the
people supporting you yeah and and
popcorn and popcorn thank you for
grabbing for mine okay thanks
um
this is really good I've never had that
before damn sorry I know don't you worry
I'll buy it I'll get it at Walmart I
like and Vons and Albertsons I like to
support you I'm gonna buy it um so
Priyanka and I were just talking about
um her baby earlier so you are having
another baby later this year so
congratulations
Nation
another move together no no no that's
exciting are you excited
I'm very excited yeah so he's having
another baby
we just try to confuse people oh wait
yeah
that type of stuff
yes no I was like
timing we would love to have planned it
as a matter of fact he and I uh so I'm
gonna love that I'm a January kid and
he's March baby and we have six years
apart difference and uh my son is six
years old he's genuine baby
and uh we are having a kid in two months
in June and we kind of missed by a
couple of months but they're also six
years apart we did not plan it so we're
having a lot of these kind of moments
yeah but it's it's been a lot of fun
yeah
first time father okay over two month
old I was like you're not sleeping yeah
so hard we waited for Kelly to come in
with babies new shows like just babies
babies babies I love babies too and I
give them away mine are six and eight
they can wipe themselves at this point
but like but it's I love babies
especially the skin on skin that's my
favorite thing I never knew about oh
there's what's your favorite part of the
babies
when they sleep
bath time is my favorite because the one
time I see him kind of really content
and just chilling and I get to really
enjoy that moment I'm not like okay when
what was gonna happen yeah bath time is
drastically different after like years
three well first of all minor six and
eight so I have to like force them to
clean the water on their body down
outside the house they're like I'm like
you literally have dirt like and like
your nails are brown like what's
happening you have to take up they don't
want to do it I don't know what it is
both born in Odessa Southern Ukraine and
you now have a non-profit helping
Ukraine so can you tell us about that we
had no choice really uh first of all
because we're normal good humans we have
great family values and we grew up with
Incredible parents but we also first
generation immigrants we came from that
place it's our home
our home became Brooklyn New York in the
90s and have been United States ever
since but we are all from somewhere in
this place and we value the values that
this country is on and so you know the
support that we show for Ukraine isn't
just because we're from there but also
because those people want this type of
life and this type of lifestyle and
because it's it's I think
in my opinion of how I view this country
and the gratitude that I have for the
United States for welcoming us I think
it's the most American thing to do is to
help those that are in need and so yeah
yeah agreed
I think it's really beautiful too though
when you have such a great Spotlight you
have the support system of these
families and you use it for stuff like
this we also want to highlight that on
that video uh most of the people that
came came without announcements we we
didn't ask for for anyone to come in we
just made a made it known that this is
what we're doing we're Gathering uh
humanitarian aid for refugees for people
that have been displaced first and
foremost and you know they have lived
through the effects of this crazy it's a
war it's the biggest since World War II
in my opinion so this was important for
us the people that came from all walks
of life are hundreds and hundreds of of
volunteers that we never called and
we're grateful for each one for every
penny donated and we continue in our
work you know we talk about it
um
I think we're desensitized almost can we
hear it so much but it's a crazy thing
to hear come out of your mouth like
being displaced that is literally your
life has been ripped from you and you
are put somewhere else that has got to
be the scariest thing in the entire
world like not only just for an
individual but especially if you're a
parent how do you explain that to your
kids I can't even explain them as simple
things to my 16 year old I get we just
we say it so much I think we hear it so
much in the news that we get
desensitized but it's it's an incredibly
sad thing yeah I think I think a lot of
those conversations get hijacked by
politics and we're just shooting it from
the perspective of just Humanity basic
Humanity yeah yeah we're not here to
talk geopolitics we're here to talk
about human life being like you said
making work and sacrifice yeah and also
in just for context we are living in a
generation with the largest Refugee
crisis in the world between Syria
between Myanmar between Ukraine there
are the most amount of displaced people
internally in their countries and
externally that's what I mean we hear it
all the time and I think and we're
desensitized doing this buranova 27 is
the name of this charity which is the
address in Odessa where we grew up even
starting that you know I think a lot of
times you see celebrities whatever that
means and you think infinite resources
and you think like of course charity it
just comes up like this is a really I
don't know if Grassroots is the right
term here but it's something that our
father started just out of sheer
desperation and it was galvanized by
volunteers and you know a year later
we've shipped out over a half a million
pounds of humanitarian Aid directly to
Ukraine tiny City Fort Lee New Jersey
just Bergen County Tucson
you're showing people what they can do
yeah exactly yeah
anybody can help and so from that one
city you could do that much can you
imagine it's actually world people act
actually have a social responsibility
and whatever you care for you know
that's why I think social media does
play an amazing part
um definitely Society because we can use
it to for our benefit like connecting
people and really getting messages out
there and I know everybody sees a
celebrity and they're like oh it's over
and I'm like but that's the cool thing
about when you do have celebrity you
have this Spotlight and you have this
sort of tiny superpower and it's like to
be able to shine it on people or that's
why I love doing this show to shine it
on people doing incredible things and
bringing that awareness then you bring
it into the home of somebody else that
might start something in their Community
I think it's incredible well thank you
for doing that that's really really cool
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]